you too this is your third movie that
you've done together why can't you get
enough of each other it's like okay here
we go testing Chris once again let's
make some magic
um I mean talk about this last couple of
days and all the junkets and zone and
and just how what a benefit it's been
being able to have come from that
experience and not spend fifty percent
of the movie getting to know one another
you know just picking up where you left
off hit the ground running and chemistry
we've heard from those films and any
time it felt familiar to Ford Valkyrie
we were like hearts have been similar
that's got a different direction and
some it's yeah it's been cried hopefully
she'll have me around again yeah I need
to I need to complete my Hemsworth
trifecta because I work with his brother
Luke on Westworld so I just need Liam
and then and then I don't know what
happens what is it that you love most
about each other just think you're the
greatest actor of all time I think I I'm
just human being the biggest heart and
the most beautiful actress on the screen
my wife as well she's not here I got it
listen I would take that baby put it in
my pocket it's in my pocket I'm
speechless
fifty bucks every time I said what do I
like about what I mean it's easier
I like everything pretty much about
Chris Hemsworth that was his wife saying
I heard no I you know I mean just as a
as as an actor he's so it's so awkward
to do this in person
you fool in comes a little [ __ ] I know I
bet you did it you did it for me and I
have to do for you can't leave it you
know I at comedy and actually at
everything but I think I've learned so
much just working in his company because
I'm saying this the other day Lucille
Ball famously said I'm not funny what I
am is brave and I think what she meant
is the bravery to sort of make a fool
out of yourself because in that you can
always find just genius and the truth is
I think as humans we're all afraid of
making a fool of ourselves so when one
person does it it sort of sets us free
and I think there's that's something
that Chris does in spades and it it when
he comes onto a set he knows everybody's
name he makes everybody happy just by
being there and that's really something
that is like very very rare okay I got a
character description of agent H that I
wanted to read to you and it says agent
H is one of the most admired agents in
the MIB London office I'm wondering did
you write your homeboy he well he is to
a degree I think there's evolves a few
people the wrong way yes I um sort of
roguish quality to him incident you know
has his own set of rules a little
anti-establishment at times and but it
gets the job done and and has has saved
the universe a number of occasions so
but he's also very aware of it
it carries around that accomplishment
you know and says a fair amount of set
of cockiness and swagger that he has
which needs to be kept in check let me
read your bio it says Pawnee is a
pint-sized alien with an oversized
personality who lives on a chess set I
love it what is the what is it like
getting to be a pint-sized
Wow I mean it was really fun to do this
part because I'm trying to think of
their answers of memorize because I'm
such a fan of Chris and Tessa and
they're such a joy I mean whenever Chris
walks on set he makes everyone happy in
this era right now small that you can do
a lot of experimentation and try a lot
of different things you know because
it's CG they can adjust it so I sort of
tried to do something slightly different
each take do you even get to see them
yeah I was okay and you know when Chris
walks on set he makes everyone happy no
actually what was fantastic was we've
done a lot of work with CG characters
and so on and it's often you know the ad
or the one the PA is kind of reading the
lines off-camera and you're looking like
looking at the tennis ball thing and
forget having him on set with us every
day as you said being able to improvise
and do something different was just so
awesome and and some of my favorite
sequences the sort of the banter between
the three of those characters and none
of that would have happened that way
I've been that successful without
actually having in there Chris we were
just recently with Tiffany Haddish and
she said she was really excited to team
up with you for the movie that you guys
are doing but mainly she just wanted to
see you without your shirt on I was
pitching the movie to her and she's are
you guys okay it's got a picture and I
said look you know I I'm like you I've
been auditioning an actor I've never
pitched anyone the thing i'm gonna you
know i'm never gonna produce for a
director or anything before
and I was like so it's about an
Australian strip group you know at Club
Jude oh I've been so we sat down and had
a meeting and she was beyond
enthusiastic and as energetic as I've
seen her on screen
she's Tiffany yes she ready stop
entertainment yeah I know no but she
will came to me the first time I met her
she was just calling men I say we're
walking back she's like here's the thing
I know a lot of that strip cop has been
a lot of trips up and like real does
that's what the five favorite strip
clubs and what we need to change about
the scripts yeah they're like reality of
the cheese experience okay so I didn't
realize that it had been 20 years since
the first men in black came out what do
you all remember about watching Will and
Tommy Lee fight I mean I remember how
subversive it was like the first in the
second one especially there's all these
fantastic one-liners like there's this
great moment when a the driver gets
sucked into the the car and will says
Tommy says does every model come with
one of those meaning the driver and will
says yes the old guy used to be black
but he got pulled over too much it's
like the film is chock full inside of
this universe of sort of clips that hold
that still I mean that one unfortunately
still holds up so I just remember just
you know how they take this sort of just
you know zany world and and view it with
a sense of reality that makes it a sort
of humor inside of the sci-fi world that
we just had never seen before and I
think still is so impactful and totally
holds up and quickly I heard that you
guys might be teaming up again to do a
remake of The Bodyguard please tell me
that this rumor last week and I was like
wait are we are you what you should talk
about on set history in the high yes I
started this room
we were making for he comes into work on
Monday he comes into work on Monday he
has a week and he's that good he's like
ah The Bodyguard is such a good movie I
was like I'm sorry what that's what you
can do it on Sunday was watching The
Bodyguard and I so I said let's remake
the bodyguard but let's the roles are
reversed carry me
let's watch you laugh but I want this to
happen but we need I don't know who we
need to talk to but I think that should
happen I mean come on
you know everybody's name on set she's
the most beautiful actress let's do it
[Music]